the queen and duke of edinburgh were
regular official visitors to barbados
the playground of the rich and famous
where she is
still head of state but that could all
change with their prime minister
announcing now
is the time to cut those ties the time
has come
to fully leave our colonial paths behind
barbadians want a barbadian head of
state
barbados is one of 15 other realms
around the world where our monarch is
also their queen
barbadians have discussed becoming a
republic before
most recently in 1998 and 2015
just like other countries including
jamaica and australia
who flirted with the idea the queen of
course completely understands this and
doesn't mind at all what she does mind
about
is if they leave the commonwealth so so
long as barbados stays in the
commonwealth i don't think she'll be
particularly unhappy
it isn't barbados but in reading you
will find more beijing's than in any
other part
of the uk randolph moved here in the
1990s and sonya was born here
they agree that the black lives matter
movement has made us look again
at our colonial past but it's not the
main reason that they think that little
england as barbados is known
needs a new start some changes could
change not everything has to be seen as
a negative
and i think from what i've seen so far
and heard so far in
regards to miami i think um
i think i think she can do this and take
barbados in another direction
this is just trying to raise our bar as
individual people and seeing ourselves
to be more independent and more
industrial and as i say i always was a
youngster i was like wait
can we make carrots in barbados that is
my vision certain things that i think
that
we can do as a people but i think we our
mind is just
shut shut down at the moment and i think
this will give us a chance to open up
royal tours have always been a good way
to turn on the charm and
younger royals have sometimes been
described as republican slayers
prince harry meeting the singer rihanna
in barbados was one of those moments
about making the monarchy still seem
relevant
over 68 years as the world has changed
the queen has always been committed to
her realms and commonwealth
she's heard this debate many times
before again she'll wait
for the people to decide rihanna mills
sky news